the band just got nominated for the rock
and roll hall of fame
first of all in all honesty does that
turn you guys on
or does it just really not matter is it
[ __ ] it's the rock and roll hall of
fame
no it's not it's not no [ __ ] at all you
like it you say this is a good thing
absolutely it's it's an honor of course
yeah that sounds like the political
answer but
it's just the answer it's the truth you
[ __ ] trophy
the campaign has begun
and who would you want to induct you
come on you know who is
we haven't had this discussion let's
have it now
okay well you know to be honest this
band
started with this demo tape that i did
ages ago
right five years ago i went to the
studio for five days i played all the
instruments i recorded 13 or 14 songs
just for fun i made cassettes and i
called it foo fighters
because i didn't really want everyone to
know it was me i thought maybe if i give
someone a cassette and they think it's a
band then
they'll be they'll be surprised when
they find out that it's
that it's just one person and that it
was me and you know coming out of
nirvana was like i didn't want to like
say like i got a solar project so i
called it foo fighters
one of the reasons why i did that is
because when i was young
someone gave me a record by an artist
named clark
kent it was this uh kind of weird like
fringe
thing clark kent who's clark it sounded
a lot like the police
it sounded a lot like the police because
it was actually stewart copeland
the drummer of the police made this
record under the name clark kent he
didn't put his name on the record it's
just called clark kent
and it was this cool record so when you
first got it you were like wow who's
clark kent this is kind of rad and then
someone's like that's dark goblin
so that's really the thing that inspired
me
to start the band foo fighters and call
the foo fighters and do the whole thing
so i got to be honest
i think stu would be a great guy to
induct the band
absolutely and i mean if you've ever
hung out with jew or copeland
like he can make a [ __ ] speech oh god
like
there's a bunch of dynamic i'm observing
as you say that this
is unofficial by the way this is like
coming out of my mouth it's [ __ ] six
in the morning
who is it that has the balls in the band
right now to stand up and say
they do not want stuart copeland they
want somebody else somebody
pat certainly okay who do you suggest
is that person mom oh
that's good that's good wow
this is you're you're an original i'm
with pat
i want your mother up there who gives a
[ __ ] about black pen
i'm going with your mind you know what
you're right pat's love it